I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello. Hello, hello. I have an incentive for you. Oh, do you? For our listeners. Okay. If this becomes our most listened to office ladies of all time, would you be willing to get an office ladies tattoo on your rear end? Me? Both of us. Matching office ladies tattoos on our tushes. On the old SS Bernard? It's a no for me. I hope everyone
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士们。大家好。哈喽，哈喽。我有个激励你们的提议。哦，是吗？为了我们的听众。好吧。如果这成为我们有史以来收听率最高的办公室女士播客，你愿意在屁股上纹一个“办公室女士”的纹身吗？我？我们俩。我们的屁股上纹上匹配的办公室女士纹身。在老SS伯纳德上？我可不要。我希望每个人
will listen to this, but I'm not gonna get a tattoo. Well, I've never gotten a tattoo. So I feel like the very first one maybe shouldn't be like where you work. I agree. Right? It's like, you know, if you work at Walmart, are you gonna put Walmart on your butt? Like we work for office ladies. I know. I know. It would be a really intense form of advertising. For who? For who? Just for Lee and Josh. When we start wearing those thong bathing suits that we've always wanted to wear, Jenna, we've always wanted to wear, you know, the bathing suits for your ass is falling out. You know, I love a thong in any form. Oh, you love that. You love a little string there. What are we
都会听这个，但我才不要去纹身呢。好吧，我从来没纹过身。所以我觉得第一个纹身也许不应该在工作的地方。我同意。对吧？就像，你知道的，如果你在沃尔玛工作，你会把沃尔玛纹在屁股上吗？就像我们为办公室女士工作一样。我知道。我知道。这将是一种非常强烈的广告形式。为谁？为谁？就为李和乔什。当我们开始穿那些我们一直想穿的丁字裤泳衣时，珍娜，我们一直想穿的那种，你知道的，屁股都会露出来的泳衣。你知道的，我喜欢任何形式的丁字裤。哦，你太喜欢了。你喜欢那里有一条小绳子。我们在
doing? Okay, I don't know. Guys, today we're going to talk about the incentive. It is season eight episode two. It was written by Paul Lieberstein and directed by Charles McDougall. Here is your summary. Robert California tells Andy he wants the Scranton branch to double their sales. So Andy introduces a points for prizes reward program to incentivize these doubling of sales. But it kind of soon blows up in his face. Meanwhile, Pam and Angela become pregnant walking buddies. So short lived. Shortest walking buddies ever. Fast fact number one is all about the making of the saber pyramid. Dwight is going to introduce this new
干什么？好吧，我不知道。各位，今天我们要讨论的是“激励”。这是第八季第二集。由保罗·利伯斯坦编剧，查尔斯·麦克杜格尔执导。以下是剧情梗概。罗伯特·加利福尼亚告诉安迪，他希望斯克兰顿分公司将销售额翻倍。于是安迪推出了一个积分兑换奖励计划，以激励大家实现销售额翻倍。但这个计划很快就弄巧成拙了。与此同时，帕姆和安吉拉成了怀孕散步搭子。太短暂了。史上最短命的散步搭子。趣味事实第一条是关于萨博金字塔制作的。德怀特将推出这款全新的
electronic tablet in the shape of a pyramid. Mm-hmm. That saber wants them to sell. It is very large and it doesn't do much. Well, you know, Jenna, without the battery or optional memory booster, it's barely three pounds. Yeah. But if you need a battery or optional memory, what is it like 10 pounds? How heavy is this thing? Also, it's got 50 L of memory. 50 L. Yeah, you're gonna want the booster. We had a fan question from Cameron C in California who wanted to know how functional was the saber pyramid? It looks like it might be a non-functional computer screen that you just turn on and off since nobody seems to really use it during the
金字塔形状的电子平板电脑。嗯哼。萨博公司希望他们卖出这款产品。它非常大，而且没啥用。好吧，你知道的，珍娜，如果没有电池或可选的内存增强器，它连三磅都不到。对啊。但如果你需要电池或可选内存，它大概有10磅重吗？这东西到底有多重？而且它有50升的内存。50升。是的，你会想要那个增强器的。我们收到了来自加利福尼亚州的卡梅伦·C的粉丝提问，他想知道萨博金字塔的实用性究竟如何？它看起来像是一个非功能性的电脑屏幕，你只能把它打开和关闭，因为在剧中似乎没有人真正使用过它。
show. Also, how did they make them? It seems like a pretty specialized job to cut a screen into a triangle shape. Well, guess who I talked to this morning? Please say Phil Shea, please. Phil Shea. Woohoo! Just the loveliest man of all time. He just finished doing a pilot for Justin Spitzer and he mentioned that he ran into you in Bed, Bath and Beyond with the blankets. Yes, he had every shade of gray you could buy. Mm-hmm. Apparently someone in this pilot has a gray-themed bedroom. Well, Phil told me that the saber pyramid was Paul Lieberstein's idea. It was gonna be a parody of those new tablet computers that were just coming out
另外，他们是怎么制作这些道具的？把屏幕切割成三角形似乎是一项相当专业的工作。好吧，猜猜我今天早上跟谁说话了？请说菲尔·谢伊，求你了。菲尔·谢伊。呜呼！史上最可爱的人。他刚刚为贾斯汀·斯皮策完成了一部试播集的制作，他提到他在“床品世界”里碰到过你，你当时正拿着毯子。对，他把你能买到的各种灰色都拿齐了。嗯哼。显然这个试播集里有人有一间灰色主题的卧室。好吧，菲尔告诉我，萨博金字塔是保罗·利伯斯坦的主意。它将是对当时本集播出时刚推出市场的那些新平板电脑的讽刺，
onto the market at the time of this episode, specifically the Apple iPad. And in the script, all it said was this, quote, Dwight holds up the tablet. It is triangle-shaped. Mm-hmm. Those were the only details. So Phil said that they started by making a bunch of drawings, which they got Paul's approval on. And then once they had that, they went to this place called Studio Art and Technology. And these guys did like a real kind of engineering design of it. And if you can believe it, they printed the case using a 3D printer. That's so cool. Isn't that amazing? And he said they covered it in plexiglass and they did
特别是苹果iPad。在剧本里，只有这样一句话，引述如下：“德怀特举起平板电脑。它是三角形的。”嗯哼。这就是全部的细节。所以菲尔说，他们首先制作了一堆图纸，并得到了保罗的批准。一旦有了这些，他们就去了一家叫做“工作室艺术与技术”的地方。这些家伙对它进行了真正意义上的工程设计。如果你敢相信的话，他们是用3D打印机打印外壳的。太酷了。是不是很神奇？他说他们用有机玻璃覆盖了它，并且他们
have one that was functional, that actually turned on and lit up. They even had the capability of different graphics to kind of switch from different screens. But any of that that you see, that was CGI that was done in post. It was not like fully functional. It could turn on and show the Saber logo. And then anything else basically was CGI movement on that screen. Phil said they made two of these light up pyramids because there's a famous saying in the props world, which is when you have one, you have none. Because one means something's gonna happen to it and then you have nothing. Right. When you have one, you
确实制作了一个功能性的、能真正打开和发光的版本。他们甚至具备显示不同图形的功能，可以从不同的屏幕切换。但你在屏幕上看到的任何内容，都是后期制作的CGI。它并不是完全功能的。它可以打开并显示萨博的标志。然后基本上其他任何东西都是该屏幕上的CGI运动。菲尔说他们制作了两个发光的金字塔，因为道具界有一句名言，那就是当你只有一个时，你其实什么都没有。因为有一个就意味着它会出事，然后你就一无所有了。对。当你只有一个时，你
have none. I kind of like that. Right? Mm-hmm. So anyway, he said later, when we get to some later episodes, you're gonna see more of these. And he gave me the detail about those too. But I'll save it. Of course. Why tell you now? Save it because I have a few tech websites that had their own review of the Saber pyramid. Oh, really? Yes. Not everyone wanted to unleash the power of the pyramid. You know, Angela, when I was talking to Phil, he told me a really cool story about James Spader. Oh, yeah? First of all, he loved working with James, adored him. He said he was like such a serious actor and so kind and appreciative
其实什么都没有。我挺喜欢这句话的。对吧？嗯哼。不管怎样，他说以后，当我们看到后面的几集时，你会看到更多这些东西。他也给了我关于那些东西的细节。但我先保留不讲。当然。为什么现在就说呢？先留着，因为我有几个科技网站对萨博金字塔做了他们自己的评测。哦，真的吗？是的。并不是每个人都想释放金字塔的力量。你知道的，安吉拉，当我跟菲尔谈话时，他跟我讲了一个关于詹姆斯·斯派德的非常酷的故事。哦，是吗？首先，他非常喜欢跟詹姆斯合作，非常崇拜他。他说他是一个非常严肃的演员，对每个人都那么亲切和感激，
with everyone. And he said, you know, for the episode The List, when Robert California says, I never use a pen that he only writes in pencil, he said that James Spader came up to him and said, Phil, could I please get an assortment of different mechanical pencils so that I can choose the exact right one because he believed his character had an attachment to like a particular mechanical pencil, but he didn't know. He was like, I'll know it when I see it. And so Phil was so excited to go out and buy like 12 mechanical pencils. He made Phil's day. I know. All right. Are you ready for FastFact number two? I am. FastFact
他说，你知道的，对于《名单》那一集，当罗伯特·加利福尼亚说我从不用钢笔，他只用铅笔写字时，他说詹姆斯·斯派德走到他面前说：“菲尔，我能要各种不同的自动铅笔吗，这样我就可以挑选出最精确的那支？”因为他相信他的角色对某种特定的自动铅笔有一种依恋，但他自己还不知道。他说：“我一看到它就会认出来。”于是菲尔非常兴奋地出去买了大约12支自动铅笔。这让菲尔开心了一整天。我知道。好了。你们准备好听趣味事实第二条了吗？我准备好了。趣味事实
number two is the email that we got from Miles McNutt, Angela. I loved this email. I have been waiting for us to share it, Jenna. You have to tell everyone. All right. Our associate producer Ainsley was going through the Office Ladies mailbox and she found this letter from Miles McNutt. And I'm going to read it. Ready? Mm hmm. He says, greetings. My friends and followers were kind enough to alert me that my AV Club reviews have made it onto the podcast as the seventh season reaches its conclusion. And I want to thank you for bringing back fond memories of my time covering the show. I've become a media
第二条是安吉拉，我们收到了迈尔斯·麦克纳特的电子邮件。我超喜欢这封邮件。我一直等着我们来分享它呢，珍娜。你得告诉大家。好吧。我们的副制片人艾恩斯利在查看“办公室女士”的收件箱时，发现了这封来自迈尔斯·麦克纳特的信。我要把它读出来。准备好了吗？嗯哼。他说：“问候你们。我的朋友和粉丝们非常友善地提醒我，随着第七季接近尾声，我的影评网（AV Club）评论已经登上了这档播客，我想感谢你们勾起了我报道这部剧的美好回忆。在此期间，我已经成为了一名传媒
professor in the intervening period and rate my professors has tagged me as a quote, tough grader. So let the record show that I am nothing if not consistent. In the meantime, I look forward to hearing how Jenna felt about my take on the rest of the season and highly recommend she stopped reading my reviews in season eight for all of our sakes. Well, now I can't wait. Now I can't wait for you to read them. Oh, well, believe me, I'm not stopping. But he said that we should reach out if we ever want to hear how he feels about the show. He said, you know, he has different feelings about the show in hindsight,
教授，‘评教网’给我贴上了‘评分严厉’的标签。所以有据可查的是，我如果不是别的什么，至少是一如既往的严格。与此同时，我期待着听到珍娜对我在其余季度的看法的感受，为了我们大家的利益，我强烈建议她在第八季时停止阅读我的评论。”好吧，现在我等不及了。现在我等不及要读你的评论了。哦，相信我，我可不会停下来。但他说，如果我们想听听他对这部剧的感受，我们应该随时联系他。他说，你知道的，比起实时观看，在多年之后回顾这部剧时，他有了不同的感受，
having watched it still many years later rather than in real time. And I thought that would be kind of fascinating. We have to reach out to him. Oh, for sure. We have to have a whole opening of the show with Miles McNutt. He's fast back one, two and three. I agree. Well, for the premiere of season eight last week's episode, the list he gave that episode a B. Not so bad. Not bad for Miles. And he said this. He said he thought that at the end of the day, the idea of Andy as boss and Robert California as CEO had the potential to increase the longevity of the show beyond Steve Carell's exit. I mean,
我觉得这会非常迷人。我们必须联系他。哦，当然。我们必须专门有一段开场来聊聊迈尔斯·麦克纳特。他就是趣味事实一、二和三。我同意。好吧，对于第八季的首播，也就是上周的剧集《名单》，他给那一集打了个B。不算太坏。对迈尔斯来说不赖。他是这么说的。他说他认为归根结底，安迪担任老板、罗伯特·加利福尼亚担任首席执行官的想法，有潜力在史蒂夫·卡瑞尔退出后延长这部剧的寿命。我是说，
that's promising. That's a good endorsement. He said he looked forward to continuing to cover the show and seeing how the season would unfold. As for the incentive, he gave it a C. So maybe maybe this is where we start to go downhill. I really wonder what our lowest grade is going to be. Oh, no, I'm scared. Like, I wonder if we get an F. Oh, my God, I can't. We never had an F episode. Never. That I am certain of. We don't think so. But Miles is a tough grader. I mean, or maybe a D. We have to keep checking in.
这很有希望。这是一个很好的背书。他说他期待继续报道这部剧，并看看这一季将如何展开。至于《激励》这一集，他给了它一个C。所以也许，也许这就是我们开始走下坡路的地方。我真的很想知道我们的最低评分会是什么。哦，不，我好害怕。天哪，我在想我们会不会得一个F。哦，天哪，我不行。我们从来没有得过F的剧集。从来没有。这一点我很确定。我们不这么认为。但迈尔斯是一个评分很严的人。我是说，或者也许是个D。我们得继续关注。
You know, we will. He did say that this episode of the incentive was similar to some of the early years of the office. And he said that, like, in a good way. But he also said that it was suggestive of a very aimless season that threatened to wear out his patience with the series. Yeah. Tell us. Tell us what you really think, Miles. He also did not care for our dual pregnancy storyline. Oh. But his complaint was that they weren't doing enough with it to make it interesting. He thought they could have done more. I agree. There you go.
你知道的，我们会关注的。他的确说过，《激励》这一集和《办公室》早期的某些年份很相似。他说这话时是褒义的。但他也说过，这暗示了这一季有些漫无目的，这威胁到了他对这部剧的耐心。好吧。告诉我们。告诉我们你的真实想法，迈尔斯。他也并不喜欢我们的双孕妇剧情线。哦。但他的抱怨是，他们没有在这条线上做足够多的文章来让它变得有趣。他认为他们本可以做得更多。我同意。给你说中了。
Yeah, I agree, Miles. It was such a fun idea. And then it didn't pay off the way I had hoped it would with more storyline. It kind of petered out a little bit. Yeah. All right. Well, moving on to fastback number three, fastback number three is a little bit of office ladies news. That's a little bit about what happened over spring break. Specifically, what happened to me over spring break. Yeah. Which is that I broke my right shoulder in a sort of skiing accident. I got a text from Jenna that simply said I broke my shoulder.
是的，我同意，迈尔斯。这是一个如此有趣的主意。但它并没有像我希望的那样以更多剧情线的方式得到回报。它有点虎头蛇尾了。是的。好吧，接下来进入趣味事实第三条，趣味事实第三条是一点关于“办公室女士”的新闻。也就是一点关于春假期间发生的事情。具体来说，是关于我在春假期间发生了什么。是的。也就是我在一次滑雪事故中摔断了右肩。我收到了珍娜发来的一条短信，上面简单写着：“我摔断了肩膀。”
I was in the emergency room and I couldn't really use my arm yet, but I felt compelled to tell my BFF what had happened. Of course. Of course. And I'm with Josh. We were running errands and I said, Jenna said she broke her shoulder. And he goes, and it's April 1st. She's pranking you. This is maybe like an April Fool's joke. And I said, no, no, no, Josh, we don't prank each other. We don't like being pranked and we don't prank each other.
我在急诊室，我还不能怎么用我的胳膊，但我忍不住想把发生的事告诉我的闺蜜。当然。当然。当时我和乔什在一起。我们正在跑腿，我说：“珍娜说她摔断了肩膀。”结果他说：“今天是4月1日。她在捉弄你。这大概是个愚人节玩笑吧。”我说：“不，不，不，乔什，我们不会互相捉弄的。我们不喜欢被捉弄，我们也不会捉弄彼此。”
I am telling you, this is real. And then I texted you, oh my gosh, are you okay? And then we didn't hear from you. And then finally, I was like, I texted Lee and I was like, please tell me, is she okay? What's going on? And when we hadn't heard from you in a bit, Josh was like, I think she's pranking. I was like, no, drop it. I know she's not. I would never. I would never.
我告诉你，这是真的。然后我给你发了短信：“哦天哪，你还好吗？”然后我们没收到你的回复。最后，我有点急了，我给李发了短信，我说：“请告诉我，她还好吗？怎么回事？”当我们有一段时间没有你的消息时，乔什就说：“我觉得她在恶作剧。”我说：“不，别想了。我知道她才没有。我绝不会。我绝不会。”
When you told me that story, I thought, you know me better. I knew you better. I would never prank you. I never doubted it for a second. So here's what happened, everyone. We were in Aspen, Colorado for spring break. We were skiing, we skied for six days. Great skiing, wonderful time. It's 4 p.m. on our last day of skiing.
当你跟我讲那个故事时，我想，你明明更了解我。我更了解你。我绝不会捉弄你。我一秒钟都没有怀疑过。所以事情是这样的，各位。我们为了春假去了科罗拉多州的阿斯本。我们在滑雪，滑了六天。滑雪很棒，度过了美好的时光。那是我们滑雪最后一天下午4点。
Last day you were flying out the next morning. Yes. And in order to get back to our friend's house, there was this option. At the end of the ski run, you can either take off your boots, walk down like a tiny embankment, and then carry your skis back to their house along this snowy sidewalk. Or you can sort of scoochie yourself down the embankment on your skis and then sort of pull yourself along the snowy sidewalk back to their house. You're not even on the mountain anymore.
最后一天，你第二天早上就要飞走了。是的。为了回到我们朋友的家里，当时有一个选择。在滑雪道的尽头，你可以脱下靴子，走下一段很小的路堤，然后沿着这条积雪的人行道把滑雪板扛回他们家。或者你可以踩着滑雪板顺着路堤滑下去，然后沿着积雪的人行道把自己拉回他们家。你甚至都不在山上了。
You're not even on a run. Nope, I'm not. And I knew better. I knew better. This is not what I'm good at. Kind of like these little moves. I don't do tree trails. I don't do anything that requires sort of precision with the skis. And it was really slushy.
你甚至不在滑雪道上了。不，我不在了。我本该知道更好的。我本该知道的。这不是我擅长的。有点像这种小动作。我不走林间小道。我不做任何需要用滑雪板进行精确操作的事情。而且当时真的很 slushy（雪很 slush）。
And I decided that I didn't want to carry my skis, so I was going to try to scoochie. And I didn't scoochie. My legs got all twisted. And I fell onto a slushy, very hard sidewalk on my shoulder. And it broke. So many F-bombs later, we get me to the hospital. And yes, broken shoulder. I'm going to be in a sling for, they said, six weeks, followed by physical therapy.
我决定我不想扛着滑雪板，所以我想尝试滑下去。结果我没有滑好。我的腿全扭在一起了。我重重地摔在一个既 slush 又非常硬的人行道上，摔在了我的肩膀上。结果就断了。在一连串的脏话之后，他们把我送到了医院。没错，肩膀骨折了。他们说我要打六周的石膏吊带，然后做物理治疗。
But here was the thing. I can now no longer leave the next day. I couldn't leave. I couldn't get on a plane less than 24 hours after this fall. So we cancel our flight. We're just getting our bearings. And finally, in order to leave, we had to get a flight out of Denver, which is like a four-hour drive. Yeah, you were saying there were no more flights out of Aspen?
但问题是。我不能按原计划第二天离开了。我走不了。我在这次摔倒后不到24小时内根本无法登机。所以我们取消了航班。我们只是在适应情况。最后，为了离开，我们不得不从丹佛坐飞机离开，那需要大约四个小时的车程。是的，你之前说阿斯本没有航班了？
Nothing out of Aspen. Nothing. We get on a JSX flight out of Denver. JSX is an airline. They don't fly out of the big airport. They fly out of the small, little, like, little airport. You just kind of walk into a hangar and then you get on the plane. But we managed to get seats on this flight. What was great was that we weren't going to have to go through like a whole security at the airport where people might bump me. And this was the big fear that I would get jostled, that I would fall again or something.
阿斯本没有航班。什么都没有。我们从丹佛搭乘了一趟JSX航空公司的航班。JSX是一家航空公司。他们不在大机场起飞。他们在小型的、像小型机场的地方起飞。你只需要走进一个机库，然后登机。但我们设法买到了这趟航班的座位。最棒的是，我们不必像在机场那样经过全套安检，在那里人们可能会撞到我。而这正是最大的恐惧——我会受到碰撞，再次摔倒或者发生别的什么。
So we're like, this is a good plan, even though it means we have to drive to Denver for four hours. Except on the way to Denver, we rented a car, we're one hour outside of Denver, and they closed down the highway. Snowstorm. Yep. And they reroute us the only other way to get from Aspen to Denver, which is through the mountains, which is an additional three and a half hours. Crazy. I was getting updated text from Jenna and I was like, this is like planes, trains, and automobiles. Yes. First of all, we didn't even mention that the day you broke your shoulder, the next day you had to check out of your condo you were renting. They couldn't let you stay. They had someone else coming in and Lee had to pack up all of you guys and you guys had to find another place to stay.
所以我们想：“这是个好计划，尽管这意味着我们要开车四个小时去丹佛。”除了在去丹佛的路上，我们租了一辆车，在离丹佛还有一小时车程的地方，他们把高速公路封了。暴风雪。是的。他们让我们改道走从阿斯本到丹佛的唯一另一条路，那就是穿过山区，这需要额外三个半小时。太疯狂了。我不断收到珍娜发来的最新短信，我就想：“这简直就像是《飞机、火车和汽车》啊。”是的。首先，我们甚至都没提到你摔断肩膀的那天，第二天你就得退掉你租的公寓。他们不让你多住。他们有别人要入住，李不得不帮你把所有东西都打包好，你们得找另一个地方住。
Then you had to find a way out of Aspen. Then you had to rent a car. Then the road was closed to a snowstorm. Now you're driving on a curvy, crazy road in a snowstorm, three hours out of the way. We did not think we were going to make our flight. We didn't. We had all these plans to get to Denver, to have dinner, to return our car, to then get to this little airport. We're like, we're not going to make it. We're in now a blizzard in the mountains. I thought we were going to get stuck in the mountains. I started praying. I was just like, Lord, let him get off that mountain. Just let him get off the mountain.
然后你得想办法离开阿斯本。然后你得租一辆车。然后公路因为暴风雪关闭了。现在你正开着车走在一条弯弯曲曲、疯狂的山路上，外面下着暴风雪，还要绕路三个小时。我们当时觉得我们绝对赶不上航班了。真的没法赶上。我们原本有所有的计划：去丹佛，吃晚饭，还车，然后去那个小机场。我们想：我们赶不上了。我们现在身处山区的暴风雪中。我以为我们会被困在山区。我开始祈祷。我当时就在想：“上帝啊，让他离开那座山吧。就让他离开那座山吧。”
It was so sweet. You were just like, I'm in prayer right now for you and for your safe passage. But here's the other thing that Angela did. Angela and Josh called Josh's mom and Josh's sister and brother-in-law who live in Denver to help us out. And they are the reason that we got on this flight because they met us at the entrance to the airport with a takeaway dinner of Jersey Mike's. And they took our car back to the rental place for us because if not for that, we would not have made it on the plane. We got to the airport ten minutes before our flight. When she texts me, we don't think we're going to make the flight. Maybe we'll get there ten minutes before, if we're lucky. If we can get off this mountain, we'll maybe make it there with ten minutes to spare. So then I reached out to Josh's family. Josh and I both did.
太贴心了。你当时就说：“我现在在为你祈祷，祈祷你一路平安。”但安吉拉还做了另一件事。安吉拉和乔什打电话给乔什的妈妈、乔什的姐姐和姐夫——他们住在丹佛——来帮我们一把。他们就是我们能赶上这趟航班的原因，因为他们在机场入口处接我们，给我们带了泽西迈克（Jersey Mike's）的外卖晚餐。他们还帮我们把租的车开回了租车点，如果不是因为这些，我们根本赶不上飞机。我们在航班起飞前十分钟到达了机场。当她发短信告诉我：“我们觉得赶不上飞机了。也许能提前十分钟到吧，如果运气好的话。如果我们能离开这座山，也许能提前十分钟勉强赶到。”然后我联系了乔什的家人。我和乔什都这么做了。
We were like, all hands on deck. You guys, we've got to get my BFF home. She has a broken shoulder. She needs to get home. And they were amazing. Lynn, Nervon, I mean, Josie, they all stepped up. Josh's other sister, Jory, in case you got stranded, was like setting up her guest room for you. Angela, it was amazing because when we got there, it was basically like we jumped out of the car and threw them our car keys and grabbed a bag of food. And we're like, thank you. I mean, we later gave a proper thank you, but it was that crazy. Also, a big shout out to JSX Airlines and Kevin, who I was on the phone with several times while in the mountains in a blizzard, who assured me that if I could get there, that they would let me on the plane. And I want you to know they did not know I was Jenna Fisher from the office. He was just absolutely wonderful. I've never flown this airline before. Incredible. Just absolutely amazing. And sure enough, we got there and we went up to the guy who was letting people on the plane and he said, oh, yes, Kevin called.
我们当时想：“全员出动。各位，我们得把我闺蜜接回家。她肩膀骨折了。她得回家。”他们太棒了。琳、内尔冯，还有乔西，他们全都挺身而出。乔什的另一个姐姐乔里，以防你被困住，甚至还为你收拾好了客房。安吉拉，这太神奇了，当我们到达时，基本上就像我们跳下车，把车钥匙扔给他们，然后抓起一袋食物。我们就说：“谢谢你们。”我的意思是，我们后来正式向他们道谢了，但当时就是那么疯狂。另外，非常感谢JSX航空公司以及凯文。我在山区的暴风雪中曾多次和他通话，他向我保证，只要我能赶到，他们就会让我上飞机。我想让你们知道，他们当时根本不知道我是《办公室》里的珍娜·费舍。他真的太棒了。我以前从未坐过这家航空公司。不可思议。绝对太棒了。果不其然，我们到了那里，走到那个负责放行登机的人面前，他说：“哦，对了，凯文打过电话了。”
He said to expect you. We're like, we're the people with the broken shoulder who were in a blizzard. So thank you to Josh's family. Thank you to Kevin at JSX. And now I'm going to have a broken shoulder for a while. I cannot move my right arm at all. I cannot move it. I mean, I went over the other day and I flat ironed your hair for you. She did. Yes. Grooming has been my biggest challenge. Grooming and sleeping. I have to sleep sitting up. Yeah. Jenna left me the sweetest message. She was like, and thank you so much for coming over and flat ironing my hair for me. I just needed to feel like a real person and it just made me think of when we're old ladies and we're going to help each other do things.
他说预计你们会来。我们就说：“我们就是那个肩膀骨折、经历了一场暴风雪的人。”所以，感谢乔什的家人。感谢JSX的凯文。现在我的肩膀要骨折一段时间了。我完全无法活动我的右手臂。我真的动不了。我的意思是，前几天你过来，还帮我用直发器拉直了头发。她确实这么做了。是的。仪容打理成了我最大的挑战。打理头发和睡觉。我必须坐着睡觉。是的。珍娜给我留了一条最贴心的信息。她说：“非常感谢你过来帮我用直发器拉直头发。我只是需要找回一点做正常人的感觉，这让我想起了等我们老了以后，我们要互相帮忙做各种事情的场景。”
I did. I did. You were there for me with my broken back and now you were here for me for my broken shoulder. Lady, I will always be there for you. In fact, right now, I think we need to take an ice break. Jenna is icing her shoulder as we do the podcast. And when we come back, we're going to tell you what's really going to incentivize the Dunder Mifflin gang. I like it. I like it. We are back and I have a little thing to share with you guys. From the shooting draft, there was a little note on the shooting draft when I went back and looked at it. It said the incentive is episode hashtag 08001. And that meant it was the first episode of season eight. And there was a little note that said we have decided to air this episode after the list, which was episode number hashtag 08002. Those numbers will not change, but this order does.
我是这么想的。我是这么说的。我脊椎骨折时你在我身边，现在我肩膀骨折了你又在这里。亲爱的，我会永远陪着你的。事实上，现在我觉得我们需要休息一下去敷个冰袋。珍娜在录播客的同时正在给肩膀敷冰。等我们回来后，我们将告诉你到底是什么在真正激励着邓德米夫林的伙伴们。我喜欢。我喜欢。我们回来了，我有一小件事要和大家分享。从拍摄剧本来看，当我回过头去看时，拍摄剧本上有一个小注释。上面写着：“《激励》是第08001集。”这意味着它是第八季的第一集。上面还有一个小注释，写着：“我们决定在《名单》播出后播放这一集，而《名单》是第08002集。”这些数字不会改变，但播放顺序变了。
Yes, I was watching this episode and when it opens, I thought, why does my belly seem smaller than last week? And it's because we shot this episode first, but it aired second. And rewatching this episode, Jenna, I forgot what a big storyline Kevin has in this episode. He has, first of all, he's the whole cold open. And I'm pretty sure this is one of the most quoted things Brian gets said to him, like, of the Kevin Lines top five. It all starts with Jim becoming concerned because Kevin is answering everything in really short, like, sentences like, me got it, thank, you know, stuff like that. He's like, hmm, what's going on? He brings Pam over. And the more Kevin talks or actually the less he talks, they're like, okay, you know what, we need to get you to a hospital. And Angela and Oscar like, no, no, no, he's fine. He's always been like this. And Jim and Pam are like, no, no, no, he hasn't always been like this. And we're like, yes, he has. Oscar thinks he's making some, you know, statement. And Angela just thinks this is who he is. And Jim and Pam are like, no, we've got to get to the bottom of this. They bring him into Andy's office. And this is where we find out that Kevin has decided he can save a lot of time by speaking with less words.
是的，我在看这一集的时候，当它开场时，我想：为什么我的肚子看起来比上周小呢？那是因为我们先拍摄了这一集，但它是第二集播出的。重温这一集时，珍娜，我忘了凯文这一集的戏份有多重。首先，他承包了整个冷开场。而且我很确定这是布莱恩经常被别人引用的台词之一，可以说是凯文台词的前五名。这一切都始于吉姆开始担心，因为凯文回答所有事情都用非常简短的句子，比如“我懂，谢了，你知道的”之类的。他在想：“嗯，怎么回事？”他把帕姆叫了过来。凯文说得越多——或者实际上他说得越少——他们就越觉得：“好吧，你知道吗，我们得送你去医院。”而安吉拉和奥斯卡则觉得：“不，不，不，他挺好的。他一直都这样。”吉姆和帕姆则说：“不，不，不，他以前可不这样。”我们则说：“不对，他一直都这样。”奥斯卡认为他在表达某种观点，而安吉拉只是觉得这就是他本来的人。吉姆和帕姆则说：“不行，我们得把这事弄个水落石出。”他们把他带到安迪的办公室。在这里我们发现，凯文决定通过少说词来节省大量时间。
That's right. And with all of his save time, he's going to see world. Mm hmm. See world with the fish, not see the world. Oh, but he says China. He does. So Jim is really not sure if he means he's going to see the world or go to see world with all his extra time. I think this is the line that Brian gets quoted a lot. Why waste time say lot words when few word do trick? Mm hmm. Andy's going to say, here's the deal, Kevin, I appreciate what you're trying to do. I really do. But here we have a word code, kind of like, you know, how you have a dress code.
没错。用他省下来的所有时间，他要去环游世界（see world）。嗯哼。去看海洋世界（Sea World）的鱼，而不是环游世界。哦，但他说是去中国（China）。确实如此。所以吉姆真的不确定他是指环游世界，还是用他所有多余的时间去看海洋世界。我想这是布莱恩经常被引用的那句台词。为什么要浪费时间说很多词，当少数词就能搞定？嗯哼。安迪要说了：“听着，凯文，我赞赏你的尝试。我真的赞赏。但这里我们有词语规范，有点像，你知道的，你们有着装规范一样。”
So Andy goes on to say, Kevin, sometime words you know need use but need need for talk talk. Yeah. Kevin's like, fine, I'll talk normally. I have two catches early on. I do too. Is yours at one minute nine seconds? Mine's at 22 seconds. What? Audi belly button.
于是安迪接着说：“凯文，有时候你懂的词需要用，但需要为了聊天聊天才说。”好吧。凯文说：“好吧，我会正常说话的。”我早期发现了两个穿帮镜头。我也是。你的在1分9秒吗？我的在22秒。什么？外突的肚脐眼。
You have an Audi? You can see my, my belly button from my big old pregnant belly. And then at 38 seconds, I want to talk for a moment about your very thin black headband that you're wearing, Angela, with your ponytail. Okay. It's such an interesting look to put this very thin headband on with your ponytail. Oh, it's decorative. It has no job. Right. It's just decorative.
你有个外突的肚脐眼？从我这个大大的孕肚上能看到我的肚脐眼。然后呢，在38秒时，我想聊一会儿你戴的那根非常细的黑色发箍，安吉拉，搭配着你的马尾辫。好吧。把这个非常细的发箍和马尾辫搭配在一起，这造型真有趣。哦，这是装饰性的。它没有实际用途。对吧？它只是装饰。
Okay. That's all. I can tell you it's double headache because you have ponytail and headband. This is why I thought it was odd. Mm hmm. By the end of the day, you're like, get this off of me. What are your catches? Well, mine is at one minute nine seconds.
好吧。就这样。我能告诉你的是，这简直是双重头痛，因为你既扎了马尾辫又戴了发箍。这就是为什么我觉得这很怪。嗯哼。到了傍晚，你就会想：“快把它从我头上拿下来。”你的穿帮镜头是什么？好吧，我的是在1分9秒。
There is the poster of the friendship is the music of life. You know, the one that Ellie Kemper stole at the end of the series. Yes. And I was thinking about it because, you know, my character is not on the poster, but it makes sense because would Andy really put Angela on this poster? I mean, they don't have any fond shared memories. I don't know. I mean, you're his ex fiance. Exactly.
那里有一张海报，上面写着“友谊是生命的音乐”。你知道的，就是埃莉·肯珀在剧集结尾偷走的那张。对。我当时在想，你知道的，我的角色不在海报上，但这很合理，因为安迪真的会把安吉拉放上这张海报吗？我的意思是，他们没有什么美好的共同回忆。我不清楚。我是说，你可是他的前未婚妻。没错。
And then the other thing is I caught two framed pictures of his acapella group. Oh, me. Same. Okay, Kevin. And then I also saw in a frame the whole group of Dunder Mifflin. Yeah. Did you recognize which picture it was? No.
然后另一件事是，我抓拍到了两张他清唱团的照片。哦，我也是。一样。好吧，凯文。然后我还看到了一张邓德米夫林全员的合影。对。你认出那是哪张照片了吗？没有。
I'm pretty sure Jenna, I zoomed in. It's the one that Greg gave us all as a gift where Michael has photoshopped our heads. I think it's that one. Really? I thought so. And Andy has framed it and put it in his office. I think we were all given it as a gift from Michael. Oh, yeah, you're right.
我很确定，珍娜，我放大看过了。那是格雷格送给我们所有人作为礼物的照片，迈克尔把我们的头像P上去了。我想就是那张。真的吗？我猜是的。而且安迪把它装裱起来挂在了他的办公室里。我想我们都是迈克尔送的礼物。哦，对，你说的对。
And then we were given it personally as a gift from Greg. From Greg. Yeah. Well, this episode is going to open in the conference room with Dwight presenting the new saber pyramid tablet. Phil said, if you notice the way rain is holding the tablet so gingerly and carefully, he said they gave rain a very, very, very big speech about being very careful with this tablet. And that is why he is holding it the way he is.
然后那是格雷格个人送给我们的礼物。来自格雷格。是的。好吧，这一集将在会议室开场，由德怀特展示全新的萨博金字塔平板电脑。菲尔说，如果你注意雷恩拿着平板电脑时那种小心翼翼的样子，他说他们对雷恩发表了一场非常、非常、非常郑重的讲话，要求他一定要对这台平板电脑极其小心。这就是为什么他拿成那个样子的原因。
Because they only had two. Yeah. Yes. But I think they told rain they only had one. That was smart. Andy's going to walk in. He needs to pick a tie because his whole day is about making a good impression on Robert who's coming in to the office later.
因为他们只有两个。是的。不过我想他们告诉雷恩他们只有一个。这倒挺聪明的。安迪走了进来。他需要挑一条领带，因为他今天的一切都是为了给等会儿要来办公室的罗伯特留下好印象。
But Dwight is annoyed. He's trying to do business. He's trying to show off this amazing pyramid. And Andy's kind of being Michael Scott. He is. Well, I was really curious about the saber pyramid and what people thought of it out there in the tech world during this time. And it was actually pretty funny.
但德怀特很恼火。他在努力做生意。他正试图炫耀这个神奇的金字塔。而安迪有点像迈克尔·斯科特。他确实是。好吧，我对萨博金字塔以及当时科技界的人对它的看法非常好奇。而且这其实挺有趣的。
I found an article by Todd Wasserman that said Dunder Mifflin also releases a tablet and it's a triangle. Amazon shook up the tablet market this week with its Kindle fire, but the big news and fictional tablet introductions occurred on the office Thursday night. In this episode, Dwight Schrute presents the triangle shaped tablet called the pyramid to a room full of skeptical employees. What was funny to me about this is that Amazon had this big tablet announcement. But what everyone was writing about was the saber pyramid. I saw a bunch of articles about this as well.
我找到了托德·瓦瑟曼（Todd Wasserman）的一篇文章，上面写着：“邓德米夫林也发布了一款平板电脑，而且是个三角形的。亚马逊本周凭借其Kindle Fire震撼了平板电脑市场，但虚构平板电脑登场的重头戏却发生在周四晚上的《办公室》里。在这集里，德怀特·施鲁特向一屋子满腹怀疑的员工展示了被称为‘金字塔’的三角形平板电脑。”这件事让我觉得有趣的是，亚马逊发布了一款重磅平板电脑。但所有人都在写的却是萨博金字塔。我也看到了很多关于这方面的文章。
People thought this was like the greatest burn ever on the tech world was this parody of all the tablets that now all the different companies were starting to introduce. On a website called allthingsd.com, D stands for digital Jenna. Good because they could have stood for something else. I had to double check. Ina Fried wrote this. Finally, the tablet to make HP and RIM feel better about themselves. There have been some pretty bad attempts to take on the iPad over the past year, but
人们认为这是科技史上最棒的一场嘲讽，它是对现在各大公司开始推出的所有平板电脑的恶搞。在一个叫做allthingsd.com的网站上，“D”代表的是数字（Digital），珍娜。很好，因为它可以代表别的什么。我还特意核对了一下。伊娜·弗里德（Ina Fried）写道：“终于有一款平板电脑能让惠普和黑莓（RIM）自我感觉好一点了。在过去的一年里，有一些相当糟糕的尝试来对标iPad，但
things reached a new low last night. On NBC's The Office, the fictional Dunder Mifflin team was forced to sell a triangle shaped tablet dubbed the pyramid. It's heavy, has poor battery life, and well, it's shaped like a triangle. It has enough flaws to make the touchpad and playbook seem like home runs. Oh, burn. Oh my goodness. And then as I'm looking up the saber pyramid, I stumbled across a company called saber.com. Really? What do they sell?
昨晚情况达到了一个新的低谷。在NBC的《办公室》里，虚构的邓德米夫林团队被迫推销一款被称为‘金字塔’的三角形平板电脑。它很重，电池续航很差，而且，它是个三角形。它的缺点多到足以让TouchPad和PlayBook显得像是大获成功。”哦，太损了。哦天哪。然后当我搜索萨博金字塔时，我无意中发现了一家名为“萨博（Saber.com）”的公司。真的吗？他们卖什么？
This is what it says. We are the technology that powers travel. Saber is a leading software and technology company that powers the global travel industry. I don't even know what that means. What does that mean? With decades of revolutionary first, our team of experts drive innovation and ingenuity across the travel ecosystem. Again, I still am not sure what more words that mean nothing. Saber partners with airlines, hoteliers, agencies, and other travel partners to retail, distribute, and fulfill travel.
上面是这么写的：“我们是驱动旅行的技术。萨博是一家领先的软件和技术公司，为全球旅游业提供动力。”我甚至不知道这意味着什么。这到底是什么意思？“凭借数十年的革命性首创，我们的专家团队在整个旅游生态系统中推动创新和独创性。”再说一次，我还是不确定这些更多的空洞词汇是什么意思。萨博与航空公司、酒店经营者、旅行社和其他旅游合作伙伴合作，从事旅游零售、分销和履行。
Okay, now I'm getting closer to understanding. I'm getting closer, but anyway, there is an actual company called Saber. Wow, and they do something with travel and technology and apps. Okay. Well, no one is interested in selling this pyramid. Phyllis says it looks stupid and the real news of this conference room scene is going to be Darrell announcing that his ex, Justine, might be coming into the office later. This is the real dish of the conference room scene. Yeah, and then Kevin kind of has like a whole expletive rant.
好吧，现在我离理解更近了。我离得更近了，不管怎样，确实有一家名为萨博的真实公司。哇，他们做一些与旅游、技术和应用程序相关的事情。好吧。好吧，没有人对出售这个金字塔感兴趣。菲尔is说它看起来很蠢，而这个会议室场景真正的重头戏将是达里尔宣布他的前妻朱斯蒂娜等会儿可能会来办公室。这才是会议室场景真正的猛料。是的，然后凯文发了一通带有脏话的牢骚。
I'm sure there's a bunch of lip flap. Blur that lip flap. I was curious what Kevin's actually saying, so I went to the shooting draft to see if they wrote lines for him or if Brian was just as Kevin improvising here. You were curious what he was saying. It's so clear what he's saying. What do you think he's saying? You want me to say it? Yes.
我确信有很多唇部动作。把那个唇部动作模糊掉。我很想知道凯文实际上在说什么，所以我看了拍摄剧本，看看他们是写了台词，还是布莱恩作为凯文在这里即兴发挥。你很好奇他在说什么。他说的明明很清楚。你觉得他在说什么？你想让我说出来吗？是的。
He drops the C word, right? No, I mean, it wasn't scripted to be the C word. That's what it looks like. What does he say? In the script, it says that Kevin says this. I thought you f***ing hated that psycho b***h's f***ing guts. I don't think that's what he's saying. That's what it was scripted to say.
他说的是C开头的那个词，对吧？不，我的意思是，剧本里并没有写那个C开头的词。但看起来像是在说那个。他说了什么？在剧本里，上面写着凯文说的是这个：“我以为你他妈的恨透了那个疯狂碧池的狗屁内脏。”我不认为那是他在说的。剧本里写的就是这个。
And everyone's like, whoa, whoa, whoa. And Kevin's like, hey, I am just quoting Darrell. And then Darrell's like, no, no, no, we're good now. We're good. Also, the other thing in this scene that's happening is that Andy has clearly tried to make everyone at Dunder Mifflin like part of his acapella group. Now that he's in charge, everyone's going to have a nickname, everybody. Oscar is C-Span, Dwight is D-Dub-Dog, Pam is P-Dog, Darrell is D-Dog, Aaron is E-Dog. In the script, there's a little bit more.
然后所有人都在说：“哇，哇，哇。”凯文就说：“嘿，我只是在引用达里尔的话。”然后达里尔就说：“不，不，不，我们现在没事了。我们很好。”另外，这一场中发生的另一件事是，安迪显然试图让邓德米夫林的所有人都加入他的清唱团。既然他现在掌权了，每个人都要有一个绰号，所有人。奥斯卡是C-Span，德怀特是D-Dub-Dog，帕姆是P-Dog，达里尔是D-Dog，艾琳是E-Dog。在剧本里，还有更多内容。
It's also in deleted scenes. Andy says, thanks for the help, T-Dog. And Ryan goes, T-Dog, who's T-Dog? Toby goes, I thought I was T-Dog. Jim goes, no, no, no, it stands for tuna dog. Jim is tuna dog. I kind of wish this had kept going. I wish that every week you would hear someone else's new nickname.
它也在删减片段中。安迪说：“谢谢你的帮忙，T-Dog。”瑞恩说：“T-Dog？谁是T-Dog？”托比说：“我还以为我是T-Dog呢。”吉姆说：“不，不，不，那是金枪鱼狗（tuna dog）的意思。”吉姆是金枪鱼狗。我真希望这个设定能一直延续下去。我希望每周你都能听到别人有个新的绰号。
All dog related. Apparently. Let's see. Robert, California is going to arrive to the office. He startles Aaron, but he likes Andy's tie. So good job. Andy says, hi, dad. I mean, oh boy.
全都是跟狗有关的。显然。让我们看看。罗伯特·加利福尼亚要来到办公室了。他把艾琳吓了一跳，但他很喜欢安迪的领带。干得好。安迪说：“嗨，爸爸。”我的天，哦，天哪。
Aaron asks Robert if he would like a cold beverage and he says I'll take a coffee. This is going to be troublesome. Because later she's going to deliver a very, very full cup of coffee that is spilling all over her hands and all over Andy's desk. And when Robert takes a sip of it, it is ice cold. And she says, yeah, it's very, very old, very old. This is one of those Aaron moments where I'm like, Aaron, what are you doing? What are you doing? We had a fan question from Naomi W in Michigan who said this may sound weird, but was the coffee that Robert California drank and then Andy drank actually cold or was it warm coffee?
艾琳问罗伯特是否想要一杯冷饮，他说我来杯咖啡。这下要出麻烦了。因为待会儿她会端来一杯非常、非常满的咖啡，咖啡正洒在她手上以及安迪的桌子上。当罗伯特抿了一口时，它是冰凉的。她说：“是的，它非常、非常老了，非常老。”这是艾琳那种让我忍不住想说“艾琳，你在干什么？你在干什么？”的时刻。我们收到了来自密歇根州的娜奥米·W的粉丝提问，她说这听起来可能有点奇怪，但罗伯特·加利福尼亚喝的、后来安迪也喝的那杯咖啡，实际上是冷的，还是温热的咖啡？
Naomi, I am going to assume. I don't know the answer to this question, but I'm going to assume that it was a room temp coffee. They would be very nervous about giving us like a hot beverage in a scene for so many reasons, but they would not have served a cold beverage. They would not have served like old ice cold coffee. So I'm guessing, but that would be my guess. Well, somewhere in this cold, old coffee drinking, Robert's going to realize that Andy likes Aaron and Aaron likes Andy. And Andy's like, yeah, you know what? We just, the timing has never quite been right.
娜奥米，我姑且认为。我不知道这个问题的答案，但我姑且认为那是室温咖啡。基于很多原因，在拍摄现场给我们提供热饮会让他们感到非常紧张，但他们也不会提供冷饮。他们不会提供那种放久了冰凉的咖啡。所以这是我的猜测，但这只是我的盲猜。好吧，在这个喝着冰凉老咖啡的过程中，罗伯特会意识到安迪喜欢艾琳，而艾琳也喜欢安迪。安迪说：“对，你知道吗？我们俩，时机一直都不太对。”
I mean, I liked her and Robert's like, I've lost interest. Yeah. That's it. He's done. Well, Robert is all business. He goes out into the bullpen and he is going to give what is a kind of inspirational speech about why do people choose a small paper company over a big super store? And it's because of the service. It's the personal service. And he says, now I'm going to give you a challenge.
我的意思是，我喜欢她，而罗伯特则说：“我已经失去兴趣了。”就这样。他搞定收工了。好吧，罗伯特是个雷厉风行的生意人。他走到大办公区，发表了一番可以说是励志的演讲，内容是为什么人们会选择一家小型纸业公司而不是大型超市？答案是服务。是个人化服务。他说：“现在我要给你们一个挑战。”
I want you to double your sales. This quarter, you have one quarter double your sales. Everybody is completely captivated by him. We look like we're in awe. We look like we would have just followed him right off a cliff. So this scene was the very first scene that we shot with James Spader for season eight. And I will never forget it. We were captivated by him.
我希望你们能将销售额翻倍。这个季度，你们有一个季度的时间把销售额翻倍。所有人都被他完全迷住了。我们看起来就像是被迷得神魂颠倒。我们看起来就像是他让我们跳悬崖我们也会跟着跳下去。所以这场戏是我们为第八季与詹姆斯·斯派德拍摄的第一场戏。我永远不会忘记它。我们被他迷住了。
We were in awe of him. All of our reactions of standing there and just being mesmerized by him were because we actually were in real life. I mean, he was completely captivating as a human being. Yeah. Whenever he had a big speech to the bullpen and we all had to be there, all I could think of was like, whatever you do, don't break or laugh. Not that I would because I was like, you know, slightly in awe slash terrified. But then also like, I'd be like, oh, please don't let me have a weird gurgle or a weird belly noise.
我们对 A 他敬畏有加。我们站在那里、完全被他迷住的所有反应，都是因为我们在现实生活中确实如此。我的意思是，作为一个人，他完全具有迷人的魅力。是的。每当他对大办公区发表长篇大论而我们所有人都在场时，我脑子里想的全都是：“无论如何，千万别笑场或破功。”倒不是说我会笑，因为我当时处于一种“敬畏夹杂着恐惧”的状态。但与此同时我还想：“哦，拜托千万别让我发出奇怪的咕噜声或肚子叫的声音。”
I don't know. I was wearing that fake belly. It was pushing up on me. I was gurgling during this time. I just know that like when I'm acting with someone, I'm pretty good at staying in the moment. I'm pretty good at staying in my character and seeing them as their character and kind of staying in the story. But every once in a while, there are actors that I've worked with that I can't help but sort of like leave my body and watch us from the outside. Oh, yeah.
我不知道。我当时穿着那个假肚子，它顶着我。那会儿我一直在咕咕叫。我只知道，当我跟某人演戏时，我挺擅长保持在当下的。我挺擅长沉浸在角色中，把对方看作他们的角色，并且沉浸在故事里的。但偶尔会有那么几次，我合作过的演员让我忍不住想出窍，从外部观察我们。哦，对。
This would happen to me a lot with John C. Riley. Just it would be my turn to talk and I would just be like, oh my God, I'm so sorry. I was watching us. I forgot that this wasn't like a solo performance for me that I'm actually in this scene. And that would happen to me a lot with James Bader. A lot of the time I would just like get caught up in his performance. Yeah. Me too.
我和约翰·C·赖利合作时经常发生这种事。轮到我说话时，我就会想，哦天哪，太对不起了。我刚才在看我们演戏。我忘了这不是我个人的独角演出了，我其实是在这场戏里。我和詹姆斯·拜德合作时也经常这样。很多时候我都会被他的表演给迷住。对。我也是。
That happened a lot too for me with Will Ferrell because I was just, I was just watching him be so funny. And I'd be like, oh God, I'm supposed to say something here. Ah, Robert is going to leave after he gives this mandate and Andy is going to very awkwardly sit on Jim's desk. When I saw this, I had to know, was that scripted? Was it improv? I couldn't remember. I went to the script. It's scripted.
我和威尔·法瑞尔合作时也经常发生这种情况。因为我一直在看他演得那么搞笑。然后我会想，哦天哪，我这时候该说台词了。啊，罗伯特在下达完这个指令后要离开了，而安迪则要非常尴尬地坐在吉姆的桌子上。当我看到这一幕时，我必须弄清楚，那是剧本写好的吗？还是即兴发挥？我记不清了。我翻看了剧本。是剧本写好的。
I did too because I thought, I mean, is Ed just deciding to saddle up on Jim's desk like awkwardly and shove things aside? Was this written? Was that Ed? And Jenna, I did the same thing. The script says Andy leans up against Jim's desk and then very awkwardly begins to sit on Jim's desk, knocking over a few things and shoving some stuff onto Dwight's desk. Phyllis rolls her eyes. Yeah.
我也是，因为我在想，埃德是自己决定以一种尴尬的姿势骑坐在吉姆的桌子上，还把东西推开的吗？这是写进剧本里的吗？那是埃德自己的主意吗？詹娜，我也做了同样的事。剧本上写着，安迪靠在吉姆的桌子上，然后非常尴尬地开始坐在吉姆的桌子上，撞翻了一些东西，并把一些杂物推到了德怀特的桌子上。菲利斯翻了个白眼。对。
You know, also during this, I noticed that Dwight is holding the bamboo plant in his lap. And again, I was like, what's happening with that? And I was not the only one. We got a fan question from Chloe F in Maryland who said, what's up with Dwight's bamboo when Andy is sitting on Jim's desk? Why does he hold it in front of his face? I can't stop laughing. Okay. So at first I thought he picked up the plant to protect it because Andy's knocking everything off.
你知道，在这期间我还注意到，德怀特正把那盆竹子抱在大腿上。而且我当时又在想，这盆竹子是怎么回事？而且不只有我一个人这么想。我们收到了来自马里兰州的粉丝 Chloe F 的提问，她说：当安迪坐在吉姆桌子上时，德怀特的那盆竹子是怎么回事？他为什么把它挡在脸前面？我笑得停不下来。好吧。所以一开始我以为他拿起这盆植物是为了保护它，因为安迪把所有东西都撞翻了。
Right. It's not the case. Not the case. Went to the script and there was a note about it. Did you see it as well? I did. You read it. All right.
对。根本不是这回事。根本不是这回事。我去看了剧本，上面关于这个有一条备注。你看到了吗？我看过。你读一下吧。好的。
It just said Andy watches Dwight who is sniffing a flowerless plant. I have to say, in rereading the shooting draft, Dwight has some real odd behavior in this episode. And I know part of it is because he's just decided to check out. But there are some really random scenes with Dwight. There's one later that I'm going to play for you because I was like, what is happening with Dwight? It's in deleted scenes. About this time, Justine is going to arrive. Kevin doesn't know what to do.
上面写着：安迪看着德怀特，德怀特正在闻一株没有花的植物。我不得不说，重新阅读拍摄剧本时，我发现德怀特在这个镜头里有一些非常奇怪的行为。我知道部分原因是因为他已经决定摆烂了。但德怀特有些场景真的很随机。稍后我有一个片段要放给你们听，因为当时我在想，德怀特这到底是怎么了？它在删减片段里。差不多这个时候，贾斯汀要到了。凯文不知道该怎么办。
I guess he's alone at front reception. He has a meltdown. He just starts yelling, Daryl, girl. Yes. Justine was played by Erica Vitina Phillips. You probably remember her from Superbad, the 40-year-old virgin, Veep. Her scene in the 40-year-old virgin, I will never forget it. It is so funny.
我猜他一个人在前台接待处。他崩溃了。他开始大喊，达里尔，女孩。是的。贾斯汀由埃里卡·维蒂娜·菲利普斯饰演。你可能在《超级坏》、《四十岁的老处男》、《副总统》中见过她。她在《四十岁的老处男》里的那场戏，我永远不会忘记。太搞笑了。
It is so, so funny. Google it. Like just give yourself a laugh break. You won't be sorry. That's all I'm going to say. I don't want to ruin it. Okay. Daryl is so giddy that she's there.
真是太、太搞笑了。去谷歌搜一下吧。就当是给自己放个笑声假。你不会后悔的。这就是我要说的全部内容。我不想剧透。好吧。达里尔看到她来高兴坏了。
He like winks to the camera. They go in his office, shuts the door. He's very excited. But then we never see her again. Yeah. That's what I was going to say. Or mention her at all. Where is she?
他冲着镜头挤眉弄眼。他们走进他的办公室，关上了门。他非常兴奋。但后来我们就再也没见过她了。对。这就是我想说的。或者压根没再提过她。她去哪儿了？
Is she just in his office for the whole episode? What's happening? We weren't the only ones, Angela. Fan question from Soyeon Jae, who is from South Korea, but currently living in Germany, who wrote in to say the storyline with Justine ended so abruptly in this episode. Did she appear just as build up for the next episode? What happened? Well, we both went to the shooting draft.
她难道一整集都待在办公室里吗？这到底是怎么回事？安吉拉，不只是我们有这个疑问。来自韩国但目前住在德国的粉丝 Soyeon Jae 写信来说：在这集中，贾斯汀的剧情结束得太突然了。她出现只是为了给下一集做铺垫吗？到底怎么回事？好吧，我们俩都去查了拍摄剧本。
There is a whole scene. It's actually in deleted scenes and I thought we could hear it. It explains everything. Let's hear it. Jada called me during recess. She asked me when you're moving back in. What did you say to our daughter? That we're getting back together?
其实有一整场戏。它实际上在删减片段里，我想我们可以听听看。它解释了一切。我们听听看吧。贾达在课间休息时给我打电话了。她问我你什么时候搬回去。你对我们女儿说什么了？说我们要复合了？
I just calmed down. One night together and you think it's on. You're an idiot. I told you it was a one time thing. Last night was good, right? I said touch and go, Darryl. You get a little touch and then you go. Stay the hell away from me.
我只是冷静下来。在一起过夜一次，你就觉得这事儿成了。你个白痴。我告诉过你那是逢场作戏。昨晚感觉挺好吧，对吧？我说，这只是逢场作戏，达里尔。你稍微碰一下，然后就得走人。离我远点。
Touch and go. Touch and go. You get a little touch then you get to go. I love this expression. I know. I'm looking for a touch and go relationship. I'm hot to trot and I need some touch and go. Oh, there it is.
逢场作戏。逢场作戏。你稍微碰一下，然后就可以走人。我太喜欢这个表达了。我知道。我在寻找一段逢场作戏的关系。我急不可耐，我需要一段逢场作戏。哦，原来是这样。
So yeah, in the shooting draft it said the minute the door shuts, you start to hear her scream at him because he's told their daughter they're getting back together. She's furious. And the whole entire bullpen hears their argument. And so there's a lot of reaction shots of people like awkward. And then she storms out so we know that she's left. Yes.
所以，是的，拍摄剧本上写着，门一关上，你就能听到她对大喊大叫，因为他告诉他们的女儿他们要复合了。她气疯了。整个办公区的人都听到了他们的争吵。所以有很多大家的反应镜头，看起来都很尴尬。然后她气冲冲地走了，所以我们知道她已经离开了。是的。
Instead of me wondering this whole episode, where has this woman gone as she's still in Darryl's office? Yeah. Up next is another Dwight moment that's super random. He's in the kitchen making brownies and Andy's going to walk in and it's clear that he's just trying to figure out how do we double sales? Yeah. He wants Dwight to do the work for him basically.
与其让我这一整集都在纳闷，这个女人去哪儿了，她是不是还在达里尔的办公室里？是的。接下来是德怀特的另一个超级随机的时刻。他在厨房里烤布朗尼，安迪走进来，很显然他只是在想：我们要怎么把销量翻倍呢？是的。他基本上是想让德怀特为他代劳。
I have a lot of questions. About this scene? Yes. Can I just say one thing? What if you're like, no, not about this scene. Just about life. I have questions about life. Here's my question.
我有很多问题。关于这个镜头的？是的。我能说一件事吗？如果你想说的是：不，不是关于这个镜头的。只是关于人生。我对人生有疑问。我的问题是：
Where is he baking these brownies? We do not have an oven. Is this a microwave brownie recipe? It's got to be. I also have known Greg Daniels to make brownies in a microwave. Just saying. In like a mug? Or in a pan?
他在哪里烤这些布朗尼？我们这里没有烤箱。这是微波炉布朗尼食谱吗？肯定是。据我所知，格雷格·丹尼尔斯也用微波炉做过布朗尼。我只是随口一提。用那种马克杯吗？还是用烤盘？
I don't know how he did it. I just remember one time him trying to figure that out. All right. Well, I got very curious about brownies in general. Because, you know, at the end of the scene, Dwight is going to dump a bunch of nuts into the brownies. Walnuts. And Kevin has a big reaction.
我不知道他是怎么做出来的。我只记得有一次他在琢磨这个。好吧。总之，我对布朗尼本身非常好奇。因为，你知道，在这场戏的最后，德怀特要在布朗尼里倒一大把坚果。核桃。凯文的反应很大。
Yeah. Big old walnuts. Kevin's like, no, I'm with you, Kevin. I don't want a big walnut in my brownie. Okay. Same. I don't like nuts and brownies. And I wanted to know how did the nut get in the brownie?
对。一大把核桃。凯文的表情就像是，不，我懂你，凯文。我才不要在我的布朗尼里吃到大核桃。好吧。同感。我也不喜欢布朗尼里有坚果。而且我想知道，坚果是怎么跑到布朗尼里去的？
Was it part of the original recipe? Or was this an addition that somebody made? So I deep dived the origin story of the brownie. Please, please share with me what you found. This is nowhere where I thought we would go today. And I'm getting my cup of tea and settling in. Well, here's what I'll tell you. The brownie is believed to have been invented in the United States.
它是原本食谱的一部分吗？还是有人后来加进去的？所以我深入研究了布朗尼的起源故事。请务必、务必跟我分享一下你的发现。这完全超出了我今天预想的方向。我要去拿我的茶杯，然后坐下来听。好吧，我要告诉你的是：据信布朗尼是在美国发明的。
In Boston. The first brownie recipe is believed to belong to Fanny Farmer. Let me go on a tangent about this badass boss lady named Fanny Farmer. I've been so excited about someone since we learned about Clementine Paddleford. I have a painting of her, Clementine. I stare at her every day. Well, I might get a painting of Fanny Farmer for my office because Fanny grew up in like the 1800s, the late 1800s, but she came from a family that really valued education for
在波士顿。第一份布朗尼食谱据信属于范妮·费摩尔。请允许我扯远一点，讲讲这位名叫范妮·费摩尔的厉害女老板。自从我们了解了克莱门廷·帕德尔福德之后，我就没这么为谁感到兴奋过了。我有一张她的画像，克莱门廷。我每天都盯着她看。好吧，我可能会为我的办公室买一幅范妮·费摩尔的画，因为范妮是在19世纪左右长大的，确切说是19世纪末，但她出身于一个非常重视教育的家庭，无论是
both the boys and the girls in the family. So this is very progressive. However, when she was 16 years old, she suffered a stroke and it left her unable to walk for several years and she was not able to go to college as her family had hoped. So she lived with her family and she started cooking and baking. Her parents ran a boarding house and she actually became very, very well known for her recipes at this boarding house. Such so that when she turned 30 years old and she was able to move again, she enrolled at
家里的男孩还是女孩都能接受教育。所以这非常开明。然而，在她16岁时，她中风了，这导致她有几年时间无法行走，她也无法像家人希望的那样去上大学。于是她和家人住在一起，开始学做饭和烘焙。她的父母经营着一家寄宿公寓，她其实凭借在这家寄宿公寓里的食谱变得非常非常有名。以至于当她30岁、能够再次行走时，她入读了
the Boston Cooking School and she was one of their best students and this cooking school was also very progressive. They really believed in the idea of like food and nutrition and how that contributed to your overall health. And she was so good that she ended up becoming a teacher and then she became the principal of the school. So when she was the principal of the school, she released a cookbook called the Boston Cooking School Cookbook.
波士顿烹饪学校，并且是他们最好的学生之一。而且这所烹饪学校也非常开明。他们非常坚信食物和营养以及这些如何促进整体健康的概念。她非常优秀，以至于最后成了一名老师，然后成为了这所学校的校长。当她担任学校校长时，她出版了一本名为《波士顿烹饪学校食谱》的书。
The book's publisher was a company called Little Brown and Company and they didn't think that the cookbook would do any sales. So they only published 3,000 copies of the cookbook and they charged Fanny for them. They made her pay for the cookbooks. It was basically like a self publishing thing. Yeah. Listen to this. The book was so popular that it is still in print over 100 years later.
这本书的出版商是一家名为小布朗出版公司的企业，他们认为这本食谱根本卖不出去。所以他们只印了3000本，并且让范妮为这些书付钱。他们让她自己掏钱买这些书。这基本上就像是一种自费出版。对。听听这个。这本书太受欢迎了，以至于100多年后它依然在印刷。
It has been through multiple reprints and now it's called the Fanny Farmer Cookbook. You know what I say? Good for you. Good for you Fanny Farmer. Good for you. Right. You made a wicked cookbook. Good for you.
它经历过多次重印，现在被称为《范妮·费摩尔食谱》。你知道我说什么吗？真了不起。真了不起，范妮·费摩尔。太棒了。没错。你写了一本绝妙的食谱。真棒。
That's right. I am so proud of her. Sorry for my Boston accent. You guys, I couldn't resist. I couldn't. So back to the brownie. It is believed that Fanny invented the brownie. In 1905, she adapted a chocolate cookie recipe into a bar cookie, which is believed to be
没错。我为她感到骄傲。抱歉我学了一段波士顿口音。伙计们，我实在忍不住。我忍不住。所以回到布朗尼上来。据信是范妮发明了布朗尼。1905年，她将一款巧克力曲奇食谱改良成了切块曲奇，这被认为是
the first brownie. The second brownie recipe appeared in a cookbook in 1907 and it was made by Maria Willett Howard. Maria was a protege of Fanny Farmer and she adapted the recipe by adding an extra egg and an extra square of chocolate. And it is really the second recipe that is most like the brownie we eat today. And the reason that I have told you all of this information about Fanny and about Maria is because neither of these two original brownie recipes contained any nuts, which means that you and I are right, Angela, nuts do not belong in brownies.
第一块布朗尼。第二份布朗尼食谱出现在1907年的一本食谱中，由玛丽亚·威利特·霍华德制作。玛丽亚是范妮·费摩尔的学生，她通过多加一个鸡蛋和多加一块巧克力对食谱进行了改良。而真正最像我们今天吃的布朗尼的，其实是第二份食谱。我之所以把关于范妮和玛丽亚的所有这些信息告诉你们，是因为这两份最初的布朗尼食谱里其实都不含任何坚果，这意味着你和我都是对的，安吉拉，坚果根本不属于布朗尼。
Thank you Fanny and Maria. Thank you. Yes, thank you. Well, guess what we have next? We have a little big preg, little preg storyline. Angela is going to hand Pam the current issue of parent magazine and wants to know if she read the article about the importance of regular walks. Yeah, and then she invites Pam to go on twice daily walks with her.
谢谢你，范妮和玛丽亚。谢谢。是的，谢谢。好吧，你们猜我们接下来有什么？我们有一个小小的怀孕，一个小孕妇的剧情线。安吉拉要将最新一期的《父母》杂志递给帕姆，并想知道她有没有读过关于定期散步重要性的文章。对，然后她邀请帕姆和她一起进行一日两次的散步。
Jim's like, hey, look who got a walking buddy. I'll have you know this episode aired five days after my son was born. Oh my gosh. How crazy is that? That is crazy. Yeah, that's how close to shooting versus when they air. It was very quick. Andy has figured out a way to double the sales.
吉姆说，嘿，看谁找了个散步搭子。实话告诉你们，这一集播出的时间正值我儿子出生五天后。哦天哪。有多疯狂？太疯狂了。对，拍摄时间跟播出时间就是这么接近。非常快。安迪已经想出了一个将销量翻倍的办法。
He is going to have an incentive table. He brings everyone in the conference room and he shows them all these things that they can get, you know, as they earn points with their sales. There's a polar bear stuffed animal, a raccoon stuffed animal, Sam, I thought of you. There was a frog stuffed animal, the collective works of John Irving, a brook stone, looks like many binoculars, a zippy small personal desk fan, maternity shirt, tablecloth, a curling iron. I went to the script.
他准备设立一个激励桌。他把所有人叫进会议室，向他们展示了通过销售赚取积分后可以获得的各种奖品。有一个北极熊毛绒玩具，一个浣熊毛绒玩具，萨姆，我想到你了。还有一个青蛙毛绒玩具，约翰·欧文的作品集，一个布鲁克斯通的，看起来像微型望远镜的东西，一个Zippy小型个人办公风扇，孕妇衫，桌布，一个卷发棒。我去查了剧本。
I was like, did it list off what all was on this table? No. What it said was Andy removes the blanket revealing a bunch of stuffed animals and sharper image type crap. That's very funny. Well, the face that Ryan makes in response to the John Irving collection was not scripted. And you know, one of the items that was scripted was the vibrator for 20 points. Meredith wants to know how do you get a point?
我在想，上面列出这张桌子上的所有东西了吗？没有。上面写的是：安迪掀开毯子，露出一堆毛绒玩具和“精美影像”之类的垃圾。太搞笑了。好吧，瑞安听到约翰·欧文作品集时的反应并不是剧本里写好的。而且你知道，剧本里写好的奖品之一是那个价值20分的振动棒。梅雷迪思想知道怎样才能拿到积分？
I loved that delivery. And Phil Shea made that vibrator. What? Yeah. Is it like a back massager or something? I'm not sure. So I did get to talk to Steve Burgess about this episode. I had a lot of standards and practices questions.
我太喜欢那个台词交付了。而且菲尔·谢伊还真做那个振动棒了。什么？对。那是类似背部按摩器之类东西吗？我不确定。所以我确实有机会就这一集跟史蒂夫·伯吉斯聊过。我有很多关于审查和标准的问题。
And like Randy Cordray, he saved all his emails. So he delivered. The big thing with this scene was that we could not show any logos for any real products. Everything that is on that table had to be created by Phil Shea. So Phil had to create the vibrator and the packaging. Standards and practices said, quote, we trust any visuals of the vibrator will be staged off camera. Well, standards and practices, I have news for you. It's very clearly on the table.
就像兰迪·科德雷一样，他保留了所有的电子邮件。所以他给出了答案。这场戏最大的问题在于，我们不能展示任何真实产品的标志。桌子上的所有东西都必须由菲尔·谢伊亲手制作。所以菲尔不得不制作了那个振动棒和包装。审查和标准部门表示，引述：“我们相信振动棒的任何视觉呈现都会在镜头外进行处理。”好吧，审查和标准部门，我有消息要告诉你。它非常清楚地摆在桌子上。
It's on the far left. Yeah. No one is really excited about any of these prizes. So Andy is trying to get them more excited. What else can he offer them? How about for 500 points? I wear a dress to work. This gets a little chuckle.
在最左边。是的。没有人对这些奖品感到真正兴奋。所以安迪正试图让他们更兴奋一点。他还能提供什么？如果积500分怎么样？我穿裙子去上班。这引起了一阵轻笑。
Andy is encouraged. He really leans into this now. Jim's going to egg him on. He's going to say, what about 1,000 points? Andy said, I will run through the parking lot naked with a donut on my ding dong. Now everyone's really chuckling. And Andy's like, oh yeah, you like that for 5,000 points. You can tattoo anything you want on the stern of the old SS Bernard.
安迪受到了鼓励。他现在彻底豁出去了。吉姆要拱火了。他说，1000分呢？安迪说，我光着身子在停车场裸奔，甜甜圈挂在我的小鸡鸡上。现在大家都笑得不行了。安迪接着说，哦对，你们喜欢这个，那5000分呢？你可以在老SS伯纳德号的船尾纹上任何你想纹的东西。
People go crazy. There's hooting. There's clapping. Yes. And Jim is like, oh, hold up. And we can pull our points. And Andy's like, yeah, Andy, Andy, Andy. Yeah.
人们疯狂了。有人在起哄。有人在鼓掌。是的。然后吉姆说，哦，等等。我们可以把积分凑到一起。安迪说，行啊，安迪，安迪，安迪。是的。
Well, they get there really quickly to the 5,000 points. So we should take a break because when we get back, the office is a buzz, a buzz for sure. We're back. Everybody is just on their game right now. People are answering calls, shouting out stuff. Papers are being passed around. So much activity, especially for Dunder Mifflin, when people are mostly at their desks playing solitaire. We got a fan question from Leah Kay in Arkansas who said, we're there specific directions in the script about what each character should be doing when the bullpen is suddenly working hard to reach those 5,000 points.
好吧，他们非常快就攒到了5000分。所以我们应该休息一下，因为当我们回来时，办公室里一定热闹非凡，绝对热闹非凡。我们回来了。现在每个人都状态神勇。大家都在接电话，大喊大叫。文件传来传去。到处都是忙碌的景象，特别是对邓德米夫林来说，平时大家基本都坐在办公桌前玩纸牌。我们收到了来自阿肯色州粉丝莉娅·K的提问，她说：当办公区突然为了达到那5000分而努力工作时，剧本里对每个角色应该做什么有具体指导吗？
It feels like some of the characters are just pretending to do work that they wouldn't actually do, specifically Kevin, who is frantically punching numbers into a calculator. Kevin, what are you doing? I love the chaos. Was it scripted? Well, Leah, the Kevin portion of this activity was scripted, that he was frantically just typing random numbers into a calculator. I have it if you want to hear what it said in the shooting draft for Kevin. Really? Oh, please do.
感觉有些角色只是在假装工作，做他们平时根本不会做的事，特别是凯文，他正在疯狂地往计算器里敲数字。凯文，你在干什么？我太喜欢这种混乱了。这是剧本里写好的吗？好吧，莉娅，凯文在这个环节里的行为是剧本写好的，也就是他疯狂地往计算器里随机敲打数字。如果你想听听剧本里对凯文的描写，我这里有。真的吗？哦，请务必读一下。
Because I was actually really curious too. This is what it says. Andy strolls through the office towards accounting and sees Kevin is adding like a madman to adding machines at once. Andy says, what are you doing? Kevin says, don't talk to me. Andy walks back towards his office. Oscar says, this didn't make it into the episode, but it's in the shooting draft. Oscar says, what are you doing?
因为其实我也非常好奇。上面是这么写的。安迪慢悠悠地穿过办公室走向会计部，看到凯文像个疯子一样同时在两台加法机上做加法。安迪说，你在干什么？凯文说，别跟我说话。安迪走回他的办公室。奥斯卡说，这部分没有剪进正片里，但它在拍摄剧本里。奥斯卡说，你在干什么？
And Kevin says, making numbers. Yes, that part was all scripted. But Leah, the rest of the hustle and bustle was not scripted. It was planned and choreographed by Charles McDougal on the day. And, you know, something about Charles that was so great was he was a big fan of movement in episodes. If you watch any of his episodes, you're going to see more crosses. You're going to see more kind of like background hubbub. He was not a fan of us just sitting at our desks playing solitaire.
凯文说，造数字。是的，那部分全部是剧本写好的。但是莉娅，其余的忙碌景象可不是剧本写好的。那是查尔斯·麦克道格尔在现场策划和编导的。而且，你知道查尔斯很棒的一点在于，他是剧集中动态画面的超级粉丝。如果你看他导的任何一集，你会看到更多的交叉走位。你会看到更多类似背景中的喧嚣。他不希望我们只是坐在办公桌前玩纸牌。
Not at all. You know, he was action. That's right. I noticed something as I was passing so many papers, Angela Martin, the accountant, so many papers passing back and forth. Pam is like, Angela, I am waddling around the office. There's no other way to describe it except a waddle. And it is because I probably had a front and back wedgie. I didn't even walk like that when I was actually pregnant.
一点也不。你知道的，他喜欢动作戏。没错。当我递过那么多文件时，我注意到了一件事，安吉拉·马丁，这位会计，有那么多文件传来传去。帕姆就像是，安吉拉，我正挺着大肚子在办公室里摇摇晃晃地走。除了“摇摆学鸭子步”之外，真的没别的词可以形容了。这是因为我前面后面可能都卡档了。我当年真的怀孕时走路都没这样过。
But this is the fake Prager belly. This is the wedgie that you told me about. And with each step I took, it went more up my butt. You are describing it accurately. That is the experience of wearing a fake Prager belly. Yeah, put on a leotard and then put a giant pillow in it and see if you don't get a wedgie. Andy is starting to panic. He is seeing them getting closer and closer to the goal.
但这就是那个假孕肚。这就是你跟我说过的卡档。而且我每走一步，它就往我屁股缝里卡得更深。你形容得太准确了。这就是戴着假孕肚的体验。对，穿上紧身衣，然后在里面塞个大枕头，看看你卡不卡档。安迪开始惊慌失措了。他看到他们离目标越来越近。
There's a whole drawing of like the backside of a man and they're coloring it in red like heading towards the butt as they get more and more points. He calls his business professor in a panic. He wants to know how do you de-incentivize your employees? And he does not get any of the answers he wants. Then we would have cut to this random Dwight scene. Remember how I said this episode was full of some random Dwight moments? Yes. In the shooting draft, it's in the scene. It's also in deleted scenes.
上面画着一个男人的背面，随着他们获得越来越多的积分，他们用红色把它涂满，一路向屁股蔓延。他惊慌失措地给他的商业教授打电话。他想知道如何才能打消员工的积极性？但他并没有得到任何他想要的答案。然后我们就切到了这个随机的德怀特场景。还记得我说过这一集充满了德怀特的一些随机时刻吗？是的。在拍摄剧本里，它在这个场景中。它也在删减片段里。
Dwight is sitting alone in the corner of the break room as Darryl comes into the vending machines. And Dwight just for no reason decides to narrate the whole moment. Darryl doesn't say a word. I thought you should hear it. There he is. Snack man. Snack attack. Perfect day for a snack after a day like yours. Perfect cheat day, right? What will it be? Chips, candy, giant cookie followed by a soda? Who knows?
德怀特独自坐在休息室的角落里，这时达里尔走到自动售货机前。德怀特无缘无故地开始现场解说整个过程。达里尔一句话也没说。我觉得你们应该听听。他来了。零食男。零食袭击。经历过你这样的一天之后，今天是享用零食的完美日子。完美的放纵日，对吧？会是什么呢？薯片、糖果、巨型饼干，然后来罐苏打水？谁知道呢？
Decision has been made. A chunk. It falls. Just like the food falls into your stomach. Have you always worn a belt? Talk to you later. What is happening with Dwight? Is he so bored? I'm going to say something.
决定已经做出。喀嘣。它掉下来了。就像食物掉进你的胃里一样。你一直都系着皮带吗？回头发短信。德怀特这到底是怎么回事？他是无聊透顶了吗？我要说句话。
Okay. Well, yes, he's checked out totally. Like he is determined to be unhelpful. Mm-hmm. But here's what I'm going to say. I think they were right to cut that scene. I know. I almost always am like, oh man, why didn't we have time for that?
好吧。嗯，对，他完全摆烂了。他下定决心要彻底不配合。嗯嗯。但我接下来要说的是：我觉得他们删掉这个场景是正确的。我知道。我几乎每次都会想，哦天哪，我们当时怎么就没时间放这个呢？
I'm going to say good call on that one. Yeah. That was so weird. It was really weird. And I was like, do I share it? Do I not? But then I kind of felt like I had to because did you hear what Dwight said, Jenna? What did he say? What did he say?
但我得说这波删得好。对。那真的太诡异了。真的超级诡异。然后我在想，我要分享它吗？我不该分享吗？但后来我还是觉得我必须分享，因为詹娜，你听到德怀特刚才说什么了吗？他说什么了？他说什么了？
He said, kachunk. Did Dwight just chunk it? Okay. Did he just use chunk as a verb? I think he did. He was mimicking the sound of like a can falling from a vending machine, which is like kachunk. Kachunk.
他说，喀嘣。德怀特刚刚是不是用了“喀嘣”这个词？好吧。他刚刚是不是把“喀嘣”当动词用了？我觉得是的。他在模仿罐子从自动售货机里掉下来的声音，也就是喀嘣。喀嘣。
Uh-huh. Uh-huh. No, but you use chunk to mean throw. I know. I know. It's a stretch, but it made me laugh. Listen, this is what happens to you guys when you watch an episode like four times and then you watch the deleted scenes two times and then you're like, I hear chunk.
呃-huh。呃-huh。不对，但你用“chunk”作动词通常是“扔”的意思。我知道。我知道。有点勉强，但它逗笑了我。听着，这就是你们把一集看了四遍，然后把删减片段看了两遍之后会发生的情况，然后你们就会觉得：我听到“喀嘣”了。
I must play it. You have a special like attunement to the word chunk now. I'm looking for it everywhere. Did someone say chunk? I think they did. Did someone say chunk it? It's in the cannon of the office now. Next up, we're going to have a conference room scene where Pam is presenting all of the
我必须把它放出来。你现在对“chunk”这个词有一种特殊的敏感度。我到处都在找它。有人说“chunk”了吗？我想他们确实说了。有人说“chunk it”了吗？它现在已经进入《办公室》的经典语录库了。接下来，我们将迎来一个会议室场景，帕姆要在里面展示所有的
tattoo ideas, you know, because they've won. They, they hit their mark of 5,000. So the group has to decide what are they going to tattoo on Andy's butt. And each of these is just more humiliating than the next. Yeah. The first one is a clown throwing up with a caption. I'm not as think as you drunk I am. I have a note from standards and practices about that clown.
纹身创意，你知道的，因为他们赢了。他们，他们达到了5000分的目标。所以大家必须决定要在安迪的屁股上纹什么图案。而这些创意一个比一个屈辱。对。第一个是一个正在呕吐的小丑，旁边配着字幕：我喝得没你想的那么醉。我有一条来自审查和标准部门关于那个小丑的备注。
Hmm. It said quote, please stage the visual of the clown drawing so that it is a side view of him puking into Andy's butt crack. We should not see the butt crack. I didn't even realize the clown would be puking into his crack. I didn't even get that. Well, it should be a side view. A side view, please.
嗯。上面写着，引述：“请将小丑图案的视觉效果调整为侧面视角，展示他在吐进安迪的屁股缝里。我们不应该看到屁股缝。”我甚至没意识到小丑会吐进他的屁股缝里。我根本没看出来。好吧，那应该是侧面视角。请用侧面视角。
The next one is like a stamp that says do not resuscitate, which Jenna made me think of your deep dive about when in ye olden times they thought they could resuscitate you through your butthole. You're right. Yes. Oh my gosh. Yes. You would pull down the pants and blow the smoke up the arse.
第二个是一个类似于盖章的图案，上面写着“请勿抢救”，詹娜这让我想起了你的深入研究，关于在古时候他们以为可以通过菊花来对人进行人工呼吸。你说得对。是的。哦天哪。是的。你要脱下裤子，然后把烟吹进屁眼里。
The third one is an idea from Phyllis, which the camera doesn't even show. It's too risqué. Well, we had several fan questions about this. Carolyn B. from Philadelphia said, what the heck did Phyllis draw for Andy's tattoo to get that reaction from the bullpen? And Taylor B. from Texas wants to know, were we reacting to a real drawing or was it just a blank piece of paper? I don't think we were reacting to anything.
第三个是菲利斯提出的一个点子，镜头甚至都没有拍出来。尺度太大了。好吧，我们收到了好几个关于这个的粉丝提问。来自费城的卡洛琳·B说：菲利斯到底给安迪的纹身画了什么，才会让办公区有那种反应？来自德克萨斯州的泰勒·B想知道：我们当时是对着一幅真正的画做出反应，还是只是一张白纸？我觉得我们当时没有对着任何东西做出反应。
It's not even in the script what Phyllis drew. I think we're pretending. I remember that on the day Paul came up with this idea that Phyllis submitted something and there wasn't a drawing to be had. There wasn't anything that props had made. So we staged it off camera and I think it really works. I think it's funny. Yeah.
剧本里甚至没写菲利斯画了什么。我觉得我们是在假装。我记得当时保罗想出这个点子的时候，说菲利斯提交了一个点子，但实际上根本没有画。道具组什么都没做。所以我们在镜头外演了这一出，我觉得效果真的很好。我觉得很搞笑。对。
Well, this made me curious, Jenna, about what the most popular tattoos are. And I found a list of the 10 most popular tattoos of all time according to tattoo4awake.com. Oh, I'm fascinated by this. Can I make some guesses? Yeah. I was going to put it out to Sam and Cassie and you there. They put it together a list of 10 all time favorites. You know, they change year to year, but these are the 10 they found all time favorites.
好吧，詹娜，这让我很好奇最受欢迎的纹身是什么。我从 tattoo4awake.com 上找到了一份有史以来最受欢迎的10大纹身榜单。哦，我对这个很着迷。我能猜几个吗？对。我本来打算把它交给萨姆、卡西和你的。他们整理了一份历史最爱前10名。你知道的，每年都在变，但这些是他们找到的历史最爱前10名。
Do you guys have any guesses what would be on one of these? Is the infinity symbol one of the top 10 most popular? No. Yin Yang. Well, no. A peace symbol. Oh, that's a good one. No.
你们俩能猜出其中一个会是什么吗？无限符号是前10名最受欢迎的之一吗？不是。阴阳。嗯，不是。和平标志。哦，这个不错。不是。
A shamrock. No. Actually, maybe. So here it says Celtic symbols with that. Oh, really a shamrock. Well, I don't know. Maybe not a shamrock. I'm really striking out here, aren't I?
三叶草。不是。其实，也许吧。这里写着凯尔特符号。哦，真的是三叶草吗？好吧，我不知道。也许不是三叶草。我真的猜得很离谱，对吧？
First of all, a person with no tattoos is guessing the most popular tattoos. What about like, you know, like just like a band around your arm? You know, Pamela Anderson got that and it was like all the rage, like a little barbed wire band. Sure. Sure. Okay. I'm going to say a star.
首先，一个身上没有纹身的人在猜最受欢迎的纹身。那比如，你知道的，就像手臂上的一个臂环？你知道的，帕梅拉·安德森纹过那个，曾经风靡一时，就像一小段带刺的铁丝网手环。当然。当然。好吧。我猜一颗星星。
Yes, Sam. Sam. Okay. Here they are. A heart? Yes. A heart. Okay.
是的，萨姆。萨姆。好吧。它们在这里。一颗心？是的。一颗心。好吧。
I'm getting there now. Yeah. I'm getting there too. And then Jenna, you weren't far off with like a, they have Celtic symbols, tribal designs, flowers. Okay. Wings. Skulls.
我这回猜到了。对。我也猜到了。然后詹娜，你猜得也不远，比如，它们有凯尔特符号、部落图腾、花朵。好的。翅膀。骷髅。
Okay. Butterfly. Dragons. And then here's one I did not see coming. Dolphins. Okay. Yeah. All right.
好的。蝴蝶。龙。然后这里有一个我没料到的。海豚。好的。对。好吧。
Dolphins. Sam, how many of the top 10 tattoos do you have? I have stars and a butterfly. Hey. Wow. There you go. Okay. No wings, no dragons.
海豚。萨姆，前10名的纹身你身上有几个？我有星星和蝴蝶。嘿。哇。你看。好吧。没有翅膀，没有龙。
No, not yet. Not yet. Not yet. I saw a lot of tattoos in the research of this moment. There's some really beautiful work out there. It made me wonder, you know, I don't have any either, Jenna, but like, I think I know what I would get. Me too.
没有，还没呢。还没呢。还没呢。我在研究这个时刻时看到了很多纹身。外面有一些非常美丽的作品。这让我纳闷，你知道的，我身上也没有，詹娜，但我觉得我知道自己会纹什么。我也是。
I just a few years ago realized, you know, my sister Emily for her 40th birthday, she wanted to get a tattoo. She'd always wanted to tattoo her whole life. And finally for her 40th birthday, she got one. I was a little inspired by that. And I thought, I know what I would get. What would you get?
几年前我才意识到，你知道的，我妹妹埃米莉在她40岁生日时，她想去纹身。她一辈子都想纹身。最后在40岁生日时，她去纹了一个。我受此小小的启发。然后我想，我知道我会纹什么。你会纹什么？
I would get a little cat that looks like my first cat, Andi. Andi. I would get a little Andi. I would get a little hummingbird. Aw. But I want it really colorful. Does that hurt more, Sam?
我会纹一只长得像我的第一只猫安迪的小猫。安迪。我会纹一个小安迪。我会纹一只小蜂鸟。啊。但我希望它是彩色的。萨姆，那样会更痛吗？
The more color you have? Or is that just something I've made up in my brain? Oh, that's something you made up. Oh, it doesn't matter. Like in my brain, I was like, maybe the different colors hurt. Okay. Well, good to know because I want a colorful hummingbird. Andi's about to get his tattoo.
颜色越多越痛？还是这只是我脑子里自己脑补出来的？哦，那是你脑子里脑补出来的。哦，没关系。因为我在脑子里想，也许不同的颜色会更痛。好吧，很高兴知道这一点，因为我想要一只彩色的蜂鸟。安迪准备去纹身了。
The gang arrives at the tattoo parlor. And they have settled on a design. Yeah. It's not one we talked about in the conference room. It's a baby coming out of his butt. Yes. It's a butt baby. That's right.
大家来到了纹身店。他们已经决定好了图案。对。这不是我们在会议室讨论的那一个。是一个婴儿从他屁股里钻出来的图案。是的。是一个屁股婴儿。没错。
Mm-hmm. Location alert from Amber G. in Brooklyn, New York, who said, I recognize the tattoo parlor from another show. There was a show called Tattoo Nightmares on Spike TV from 2012 to 2014. And it was about people who got really bad tattoos and wanted them covered up with a hopefully good tattoo. I'm not sure about the interior, but the exterior of the building is the same.
嗯哼。来自纽约布鲁克林的安伯·G发来的地点警报，她说：我从另一部剧里认出了这家纹身店。2012年到2014年在Spike TV上有一部名为《纹身噩梦》的剧，讲的是那些纹了很糟糕的纹身、希望能用一个好一点的纹身把它盖住的人。我不确定内部，但建筑外观是一样的。
I always wondered whether it was a real tattoo parlor or not. Can you give us a location breakdown? Yes, Amber. This was a real tattoo parlor. We shot at Madison Tattoo Shop on Magnolia Boulevard in North Hollywood, California. Mm-hmm. And the actor who played our tattoo parlor employee was Jamie Jordan. Well, Andi's going to need a minute.
我一直想知道这到底是一家真正的纹身店还是一家假店。你能给我们做个外景解析吗？是的，安伯。这是一家真正的纹身店。我们在加州北好莱坞木兰大道上的麦迪逊纹身店拍摄的。嗯哼。饰演我们纹身店员工的演员是杰米·乔丹。好吧，安迪需要一点时间。
He's going to go outside. He's going to have a talk with Jim. And he actually decides to go through with it. He's going to do it. He says, let's ink my stink. Yes. And he marches into the tattoo parlor and he throws off his pants down to his ankles. His underwear as well.
他要走到外面去。他要跟吉姆谈谈。他其实决定坚持下去。他要做了。他说，来给我的屁股上点墨吧。是的。他大步走进纹身店，一把脱下裤子，直接褪到了脚踝。内裤也脱了。
He's now nude from the waist down. He dives on top of the table. Mm-hmm. We got a lot of mail from people about this moment. Jake Jay from Minnesota said, When Andi throws down his pants and jumps on the table, did Ed actually do this? Jessica N from Rochester, New York said, Does Ed have on some kind of fleshy colored undies or something to cover his man bits? And Anna T from Toronto, Ontario says, Does standards and practices has a quote blur the lip flap for an ass?
他现在腰部以下全裸了。他扑到了桌子上。嗯哼。我们收到了很多关于这个时刻的邮件。来自明尼苏达州的杰克·J说：当安迪脱下裤子跳上桌子时，埃德真的这么做了吗？来自纽约罗切斯特的杰西卡·N说：埃德是穿着某种肉色的内裤来遮住他的男性生殖器吗？来自安大略省多伦多的安娜·T说：审查和标准部门是不是说了“把屁股的唇瓣打上马赛克”之类的话？
If so, we'd like to know. Well, Jake. Yes. Ed did pull down his pants. And yes, Jessica, Ed was wearing some fleshy underwear. Mm-hmm. Which let me tell you in itself is brave because the flesh underwear are no one wants to prance around in those. No.
如果是的话，我们想知道。好吧，杰克。是的。埃德确实脱下了裤子。是的，杰西卡，埃德穿着肉色的内裤。嗯哼。我得说，这本身就已经很勇敢了，因为肉色内裤这东西——没人愿意穿着它到处晃荡。没有。
His shirt came down in the front. Yes. So we didn't see any bits and standards and practices did have a lot to say. After we turned in the episode, they said, quote, please take another pass with the pixels to make them more opaque as to obscure Andi's butt crack in that brief moment when he pulls down his pants and lays on the tattoo parlor table in front of the office staff. So more pixels, please. Please more pixels as previously stated. I want to say I noticed a slight tonal shift in the notes from standards and practices when they were writing to Steve versus when they were writing to Randy. What?
他的衬衫前面垂了下来。是的。所以我们没有看到任何不该看的东西，而且审查和标准部门确实有很多话要说。在我们交了这一集之后，他们说，引述：“请用像素再处理一遍，使其更不透明，以便在安迪脱下裤子、在办公室员工面前躺在纹身店桌子上的短暂瞬间，遮住安迪的屁股缝。”所以请加更多像素。请按照之前说的加更多像素。我想说，我注意到审查和标准部门在给史蒂夫写信时，语气和给兰迪写信时有轻微的语调转变。什么？
Yes. First of all, in the email, they say, Steve, we are so excited to be working with you again this season. What? There's also a quote where they say, if you have any questions I can discuss with you. Just. Yes, there was no as previously mentioned. When this correspondence, I don't know. They always seemed very curt with Randy.
是的。首先，在邮件里他们说：史蒂夫，我们很高兴这季能再次与你合作。什么？里面还有一句引述，他们说：如果你有任何问题，我可以跟你讨论。就。是的，里面没有“如前所述”。当这个信函——我不知道。他们对兰迪总是显得非常生硬。
I know somehow Steve has charmed them in a way that they have a new tone. I noticed it. We'll see if it continues. Well, right as they start Andy's tattoo, PM says we've had a slight change and hands them the new drawing and Andy starts to yell out, you know, and laughter slash pain. Everyone is like, oh my gosh, this is happening. I'm cutting back and forth between Andy getting his tattoo is a talking head from Robert, California. He says, why did he choose Andy? Because he's uncomplicated.
我知道，不知何故，史蒂夫以某种方式迷住了他们，让他们有了一种新的语气。我注意到了。我们看看它会不会持续下去。好吧，就在他们开始给安迪纹身的时候，帕姆说我们做了一个小小的改动，然后把新画的图递了过去，安迪开始大叫起来，你知道的，伴随着大笑和痛苦。大家都在想，哦天哪，这真的发生了。我在安迪纹身的画面和罗伯特·加利福尼亚的单人采访画面之间切来切去。他说：他为什么选择安迪？因为他很简单。
What you see is what you get. And that mediocrity could also be why people fight for him. Hmm. There's something about an underdog that really inspires the unexceptional. Such a funny line. It's so well written. Andy is going to peel off his bandage and guess what the group did. They got a Menard dog.
所见即所得。而这种平庸也正是人们为他抗争的原因。嗯。失败者身上有一种特质，真的能激励那些平凡的人。这么搞笑的一台词。写得太好了。安迪撕下绷带，你们猜大家做了什么。他们纹了一个菜单狗。
And it's so cute. It's his nickname. It is. That was some amazing makeup work by Laverne and her team. Just really, really great. We got a really fun piece of fan mail about tattoos, Angela. It's from Ali B and Canton, Michigan, who says, hi ladies. I just wanted to pop on and say that this episode inspired me to have my own tattoo incentive in my sorority.
而且超级可爱。这是他的外号。是的。拉弗恩和她的团队做出了非常惊艳的化妆效果。真的是非常、非常棒。安吉拉，我们收到了一封非常有趣的关于纹身的粉丝来信。来自密歇根州坎顿的阿里·B说：嗨，女士们。我只是想冒个泡说，这一集激发了我在我的姐妹会里设立自己的纹身激励机制的灵感。
When I was the president of my sorority, there was this survey that our international headquarters required us to fill out every year. It was super long and ridiculous, but we had to have at least 85% of the chapter completed. This was something that my chapter had struggled with in the past. So I told them if we got 90% participation, because I'm an overachiever, I would let them pick a tattoo for me. Lo and behold, they did it and they were thankfully very kind with my design. It's one of my favorite tattoos I have and it's made even better because it was inspired by an episode of The Office. What was the tattoo? She didn't say.
当我担任姐妹会主席时，我们国际总部每年都要求我们填一份调查问卷。超级长而且荒谬，但我们必须让分会至少85%的人完成它。这过去一直是我的分会感到头疼的事情。所以我告诉他们，如果我们能达到90%的参与度——因为我是个争强好胜的人——我就让他们为我挑选一个纹身。果不其然，他们做到了，而且谢天谢地，他们挑选的图案对我的设计非常温柔。这是我拥有的最喜欢的纹身之一，而且因为它是受到《办公室》某一集的启发，所以变得更美妙了。是什么纹身？她没说。
Just that the idea of creating a tattoo incentive was inspired by The Office, but I would love to know. I am amazed by the different ways episodes of The Office inspire people. I know, right? The final scene of this episode is a tag between Angela and Pam. This is them going on their walk together since they're walking buddies. Yes, I remember filming this scene and I was quite happy to be out walking around. It was a little tough for me when I was that pregnant to just like sit in an office chair all day. You know, your legs fall asleep, you get the sciatica and the yada, yada, yada.
只说创建纹身激励机制的想法是受到《办公室》的启发，但我很想知道。我被《办公室》激励人们的各种不同方式惊艳到了。我知道，对吧？这一集的最后一个场景是安吉拉和帕姆之间的一个尾声。这是她们一起去散步，因为她们是散步搭子。对，我记得拍摄这个场景时，我很高兴能出去走走。当年怀孕时整天坐在办公椅上对我来说挺艰难的。你知道的，你的腿会麻，会有坐骨神经痛，诸如此类。
So I was thrilled for the storyline. I noticed that they had us walk on the backside of the warehouse, which was always shady in the afternoon and had a nice breeze. And this was the hottest time of our summer. So I bet we were very appreciative to be in the shade with a breeze. You know, in this scene, Angela says that she's having an ethical dilemma. Yeah. And she reveals that she has called social services on Pam because she has been having some herbal tea in mugs that had trace amounts of caffeine. My favorite moment is, I mean, this is so ridiculous.
所以我对这个剧情线兴奋不已。我注意到他们让我们在仓库背面散步，下午那里总是很阴凉，还有微风。而且这是我们夏天最热的时候。所以我敢打赌，我们非常感激能坐在有微风的阴凉处。你知道，在这个场景中，安吉拉说她面临着一个道德困境。是的。她透露说她因为帕姆喝了一些含有微量咖啡因的花草茶而向社会福利署举报了她。我最喜欢的时刻是——我的意思是，这也太荒谬了。
When Pam's like, you know what, Angela, why don't you call? And she's like, I already did. Well, we had a letter from Anna B in Russia who had something very interesting to say about herbal tea and pregnancy. Anna said, I had my baby in Finland and the official guidelines here say that it's okay to have caffeine during pregnancy. You know, there's a certain caffeine intake, which you're not recommended to go over during the day, but one cup of coffee is okay. However, Angela did have a reason to report Pam because herbal tea goes against the Finnish guidelines. You're not supposed to drink it at all while pregnant. The reason is that herbal teas might contain unknown, harmful elements.
当帕姆说，你知道吗，安吉拉，你干嘛不打个电话呢？然后安吉拉说，我早就打过了。好吧，我们收到了一封来自俄罗斯安娜·B的信，她对花草茶和怀孕有一些非常有趣的看法。安娜说：我在芬兰生的孩子，这里的官方指导方针说怀孕期间喝咖啡因是可以的。你知道的，有一定的咖啡因摄入量，建议一天不要超过那个量，但一杯咖啡是可以的。然而，安吉拉举报帕姆确实有她的理由，因为花草茶违背了芬兰的指导方针。怀孕期间根本不应该喝它。原因在于花草茶可能含有未知的有害元素。
Hmm. According to the Finnish guidelines for pregnancy care. Maybe Angela was reading up on some Finnish guidelines. Perhaps there was an article in that magazine that Pam never read that said something about it. We don't know. Pam is going to suggest that maybe they just keep their pregnancies separate, not pretend to be in it together. And they spread apart a few paces and continue to walk side by side, but now they don't talk. And I think this is why Miles was disappointed because this storyline started and stopped all in one episode.
嗯。根据芬兰的孕期保健指南。也许安吉拉当时在查阅一些芬兰的指南。也许那本杂志上有一篇潘从未读过关于这方面的文章。我们不知道。潘打算建议她们也许应该各自关注自己的孕期，不要假装一起经历。于是她们拉开几步的距离，继续并肩走着，但现在她们不说话了。我想这就是迈尔斯感到失望的原因，因为这条故事线在短短一集里就戛然而止了。
And I would have loved to have seen more of the two of them together in their pregnancies. Me too. I just would have loved to seen their dynamics some more. I agree. Well, that's it for this episode. I want to give a big thank you to Phil Shea for hopping on the phone with me to tell me all about that pyramid. And also Steve Burgess, who gave me all of those wonderful emails, those wonderfully polite emails between himself and standards and practices. And I think we have to thank Miles McNutt too, Jenna, for writing us that awesome letter.
我也很想看到她们两个一起经历孕期的更多情节。我也是。我只是很想再多看看她们之间的互动。我同意。好了，本集内容就到这里。我要特别感谢菲尔·希尔和我通话，跟我讲了那个金字塔道具的一切。还要感谢史蒂夫·伯吉斯，他给我提供了所有那些精彩的电子邮件，他和审查与标准部门之间那些极其礼貌的电子邮件。珍娜，我想我们还得感谢迈尔斯·麦克纳特给我们写了那封精彩的信。
And Miles, we're going to keep checking in. We are. We're going to track it. Gosh, I hope you never give us enough. All right, next week is Lotto. We will see you then. See you then. Bye.
迈尔斯，我们会一直关注你的。会的，我们会追踪的。天哪，希望你给我们的内容永远都看不够。好了，下周播出的是《彩票》。我们下周见。回见。拜拜。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com.
感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。我们的执行制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的录音师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿演奏的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。
For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如需免费试用一个月 Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码 OFFICE。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。